good afternoon everybody
so this is nothing new we all have
encountered this some point in our
JavaScript coding so let me shed some
quick light on a good bad at the tricky
parts it's more to do with the tricky
parts don't go with the description
Brendan Eich thanks for giving us
JavaScript and from annoying pop-ups the
JavaScript has evolved come along a long
way all these two tickets it's easy to
understand so anybody new to programming
JavaScript is appealing because it has a
very broad appeal but none of us go put
our deeper dive into understanding and
that's why when we encounter we got
issues we start blaming JavaScript
instead let's try to understand more
about it let's embrace JavaScript with
love so quickly what we learn today it's
types and questions just two seconds to
go to this and let me know if you all
know the answers to this yes or no so
the second one is influenced by a talk
from last year's JS gone for you by
Demetrius the sin of JavaScript so
trying to shed light on how it works
quick the JavaScript types seven of
these symbol is a new one newly added in
es6 the good thing is typeof null is an
object all the others type of undefined
is undefined type of boolean is boolean
type of number is number type of string
a string type of object is object I have
a question
anybody which is the seven string value
that type of can return other than these
so our type of null is an object so
which means we have like seven return
values from type of which is the seventh
type of can return it's a function so
type of function is a function even
that's not our separate type type of
function gives a function what is type
of array it's an object yes next type of
type of 42
it's a string why because first type of
42 is a number number is a string and
type of number that string number is a
string so answer to this is strain yes
okay so quickly undefined versus
undeclared we have a which is undefined
which means it is declared but it's not
given a value which is undefined right
next be the second one B is not declared
at all but the message JavaScript Rose
is B is not defined but actually it is
undeclared not undefined quick one what
is the output of this undefined yes
because the return value is not defined
so functions without explicit return
value returns always undefined then we
have this numbers it's not only with
JavaScript it's with any language which
adopts the I Triple E 754 specification
quick one one of these is true
which one one is false one is true the
second one is true the first one is
false because it's because of the binary
floating-point calculation the first one
0.1 it's hard to we don't have a finite
representation of binary in
floating-point whereas it's easier
whichever fraction is approximately
power of two it's easier to represent
them in binary in finite floating space
so that is my second one is true now the
first one next what is nan nan means I
try to perform a mathematical operation
but failed and here is the failed number
result instead and nan is the only value
in JavaScript which isn't equal to
itself okay some more numbers in
JavaScript we have the infinity and the
minus infinity as well yes what is
infinity divided by infinity Matz don't
blame javascript for all this this is
because of I Triple E 754 specification
infinity divided by infinity can be
performed by max its nan not a number
some more numbers yes we have 0 + 0 + -
0 in JavaScript yes but + 0 + - 0 are
equal to each other
it's only nan which is not equal to none
yes we still need negative 0 if we sum
if you are doing some game programming
if you have two direction
left to right center point yes we need
to know which direction we are moving
some theory go and read about it but yes
that is plus 0 and minus 0 next we all
which we all hate to avoid it's
questions right something to know before
we do questions there's something called
two string yes
sometimes you might have got a JSON
object and then we when we try say a
promise returns a JSON and then we try
to output it sometimes we get the object
string and then we wonder why because
the object gets convert converted to its
two string and then that's why we got
the object to string here we have the
array a door to string is 1 2 3 and a
string then comes the number few things
about number two boolean yes in
JavaScript will do thing to know about
us there are like these faulty values
okay so these are the faulty values all
right okay just one quick
I said it right
okay oh right this is gonna be really
quick I want you to stop using react Jes
and being a developer is a bit like
being a lawyer if how are we going to
get these big books if we do stuff that
everybody can understand if you take six
days instead of six months to get to
grips with the codebase and that means
your firm can replace you it gets even
worse with immutable state and once you
have an object nothing can change it
what if if you don't have 37 different
things that can randomly change state
firing events when it rains on Tuesdays
except in Firefox your manager can
understand it your manager can do your
job testing without a browser if not
leaving a multi virtual machine selenium
test rig that takes three days to set up
and four days to run is not good if you
are paid by the hour and if you don't
believe me let's look at history there
are four people approximately in the
worlds that can write a send mail config
from scratch it looks like this these
people worked three days they had happy
lives they were rich and then people
came and invented axiom and postfix and
of those four people three an hour on
employees and two homeless
pause for a moment just read the slide
is important and so to help stop this
phenomenon um I helped organize the
Hamburg react self-help group which we
have about three sharings a month you're
all very welcome to come and join us um
and let's rid the world of this horrible
framework okay I just is a style crawler
it's an automatic CSS crawler that'll
download like it'll download styles and
show you the like the main styles that a
site uses and it takes screenshots and
takes like the navigation in the main
like the main everything it's it's quite
easy to use the other awesome thing is
that everybody how everybody hates on
Phantom jeaious this does not use it and
I wanted to make sure people knew about
like our about nightmare because it's
amazing I'm not affiliated with it but
it's great
okay so nightmare example very simply
like it's a lot of this head up is the
same as phantom we can show the style
and that's going to open the page
pulling all these CSS analyze
screenshots okay good works I think
that's the first live demo I've seen
today that worked yeah so this is the
size it makes there's just pulling it in
from the site this is the main like the
CSS of the footer the header of the
background etc and then we have the main
colors that are all based on
they're all off-screen yeah somebody
pulls in these and it bases the colors
off these with a nifty little NPM
library and yeah that's pretty much
about it actually we're actually using
it for and where I work for embedding
magazines because we embed them in other
people's sites and so we need to know
exactly what their what their page looks
like and so we can take that and
automatically pull in their styles to
apply them to our to our embedded things
and yeah it's cool check it out it's a 9
p.m.
also check out check out nightmare cuz
it's way way way better than phantom Jas
and it's based on electron I believe
yeah okay hello my name is Michelle with
one L and I wanted to know why aren't
you giving talks yet it's because you
have a whole bunch of excuses so we're
going to go through and knock them all
out so you don't have any more excuse
number one you think oh I don't have
anywhere to speak that's not true there
are tons of speaking opportunities for
you I'm sure whatever city you live in
there's tons of meetups you can find
coding workshops where usually they have
beginners and that's a really good low
low pressure place to get started you
can go to conferences you can go to
unconferences and there's a range of
lengths from lightning talks to 20
minutes 30 minutes hour long there's
something for everybody
maybe you think oh people are gonna
judge me
no actually brains are really forgiving
of speak people make mistakes all the
time when you're talking and our brains
just correct them and additionally
people don't care as much as you think
they care you're
it's true you're judging yourself a lot
more harshly than everyone else is
judging you maybe you think oh people
are just natural born speakers speaking
well just comes naturally to some people
false it's just like any other skill you
practice it may be some people have some
more natural talent than others it
doesn't matter anybody can practice and
get better when I first started giving
talks I actually practiced my talk at
home to myself in the shower and then in
front of the mirror so I could see what
I looked like and what weird things I do
with my hands you just practice maybe
you think oh I'm not an expert in
anything I can't give a talk that's not
true you are qualified to give a talk on
many topics right now exactly as you are
additionally even if you are an expert
in something a talk is really not the
best format to showcase that you
probably want to do some kind of longer
in-depth article or book or something
maybe you think you have to be a people
person to be a good speaker guess what
introverts can make great speakers
additionally it makes it really easy
when you go to a conference or any kind
of social event if you're not really
great at going up to people and starting
conversations yourself if you give a
talk it gives people a reason to come
over to you and then if you're tired of
interacting you just go hide it's fine
maybe you're too scared guess what there
are two types of speakers those that are
nervous and those that are liars
said by Mark Twain if you can
comfortably hold a conversation you can
give a talk furthermore the body's
reaction to fear and excitement is the
same so it becomes a mental decision am
i afraid or am i excited it's just in
your head okay now we're past all that
maybe you think oh I don't have anything
to talk about
well the average person says 15,000
words a day you have something to talk
about I'll give you some ideas maybe you
want to talk about a problem you solved
that's always interesting for people to
hear anything that makes you feel
feelings if you're passionate about
something
well like listening to you talk about it
you can compare to unlike things that
you enjoy maybe you have a background in
something non-traditional and you can
find a way to compare that to
programming for example or some specific
thing you can tell a story people read
books they play games they like to hear
stories a topic that you want to learn
more about maybe you decide you want to
learn more about a topic so you can give
a talk about it and also the topic
doesn't have to be unique you can put
your own individual spin on something
okay you don't know how to write a
proposal it's just your elevator pitch
it's exactly what everybody did in the
morning here just make it really short
why do people want to listen to it maybe
you think you must have the entire
presentation ready before submitting the
proposal no you can propose a talk
before even thinking about how you would
present there's always a bit of time
you'll have time to prepare from the
time it gets accepted maybe you think oh
I don't know any other speaker tricks
guess what just fake it till you make it
let yourself make mistakes you'll get
better as you go also you can ask other
speakers for help and now you're
thinking oh it doesn't matter it would
just be a waste of time no you get to
share your knowledge gain deeper
understanding of a topic go cool places
meet new people get a new hobby
inspire someone challenge and surprise
yourself and finally I want to say I
helped organize Berlin jeaious it's
every third Thursday of the month please
come speak there you can find all your
stuff here and I will tweet this out to
you thank you
you
okay so my presentation is based on my
last nine months or so working as a
junior developer so it's basically how
to help juniors especially those who are
not coming with a computer science
background so first of all hire them I
am on so many slack channels email
groups Facebook groups for juniors like
juniors are awesome women in tech and
it's great when you get a story like
yeah I forgot my first junior developer
job but it is actually very rare in
these groups but before you decide to
hire them you have to ask yourself some
questions you have to figure out am I
prepared to support a junior so that
they're successful at my company so
first I would ask myself in your
position in addition to having the money
to pay a junior developer do I have the
human resources and capabilities to
support them so how many hours per week
can my team support the dream developer
am i able to actually have this
structured in place an issue that I've
experienced and other junior developers
that I know have experienced is that
they're offered help but it's not built
into the bi-weekly sprints or the
workload so it ends up being you have a
question and it can be or you have
something that you to learn it'll be
addressed when there's time or when this
projects done and before the next
project and that's not a great
environment to learn in the other
question to ask yourself is are you
willing to require teaching is part of a
developer role when you're hiring mid
and senior develop level developers I
often see ads that say like must like
ping pong must be willing to go on fun
trips I think that if you're able to put
that in a job description you should
also be willing to ask for teaching as a
skill from your senior level developers
you should also ask yourself how do your
current does your current team
communicate are they doing pair
programming are they doing code reviews
are they talking every morning about
things they work on if you don't already
have a culture of open communication
it's going to be really hard for your
junior developer if you'll come
able to ask questions and ask for help
also when you're usually in a when
you're in a open communication culture
you usually have the language to explain
things as much as I've I've experienced
also senior developers who have a really
good intent in teaching me at workshops
and other things but it becomes very
clear to me when they do not have the
experience to put the training in
because they do not use words that I
understand and yes so why should you put
all this in place like what it sounds
like a lot of work why am I gonna do
this to higher juniors well first I want
to ask do any of you have like a super
easy time filling open positions at your
company if you do raise your hand okay
so basically everyone won't senior
developers you know people have mastered
their craft well they don't come out of
nowhere they have to learn and lots of
times they say well you know we're just
starting we want it to be really good at
first have money and then we'll hire
juniors but you're putting it off often
like on teams when they say this isn't
the ideal way that we want to build this
project but we'll just refractor it
later the costs are gonna be much higher
if you keep putting it off the others is
the other benefits hiring juniors is
that if you yeah if you make your
developers teach what they know they'll
have to do a lot of self-reflection
they'll have to think about what do i do
how do I do it and that would be really
beneficial for your work going forward
the other is that I've I've met
mid-level and senior level developers
who do lots of daily tasks that they
think pulls them away from work that
could make the product better so think
about how you can delegate these kind of
more simple tasks and Delic and hire
junior to do them the other is you won't
have as hard of a time thinking about
your tech stack if you're hiring a
junior and you can tell that they are
interested in learning and our have a
way of thinking that works with your
team your tech stack will be their text
deck and you won't have to worry about
that no yep so that's basically best way
to hire held
yours is hire them and support them
thank you
yes oh no my voted for my talk I
proposed so I dig into it and force you
to see it because I think this is
important and this wasn't the first
slide as I start here so commit messages
please stop writing commit messages
please I want to give you a brief
introduction commit message formats at
the example of the angular can one
commit message format but you can apply
all what I'm saying - any other commit
message format it doesn't really matter
so yeah - TX bla bla I work at gym no
please
yeah we have we're hiring um so this is
the commit lock you can see it but you
will get inside this is commitment lock
of a project that had been founded by 25
million past year we have something like
update test and I wondering what are the
unit tests was it an a/b test
why hasn't been updated was it broken
before or is it even better now I don't
know
yeah good commit review what has been
reviewed what was the outcome of the
review and why has it been reviewed I
don't know
use proper domain well it's this domain
want to you do we want to use this why
does it affect me I don't know
we have commits like change the extra
the lower dimensions and I wanna - what
where they changed why and do we have an
extra level dimensions I don't know
compress it hard but stay sexy
compressed what why and is compressing
unsexy we don't know that
yeah so adding more classes you you get
the idea and we can do better than that
like we're the angular angular commit
message format so the idea is to have
this as your subject line you have a
type a scope and a subject for example a
commit message like feature JSON Kampf
2016 set up an epic conference so we can
see yeah let me dig into that so the
type is about what am i doing I can do a
back fix I can add a new feature I can
write documentation and there are more
types you can read that up if you want
to the scope is about where I'm on doing
it so I can fix the image editor or the
profile picture okay I can update the
dogs and the readme and then we have a
subject and that's about how am i doing
it so basically that's your formal
commit message what you used to what you
used to write and now it is in the
context of a type in the scope yeah so
the benefits of this there are there is
more to it
YUM there are guidelines about how to
write proper body to a commit message
and what's how to write a future where
you where you fix your issues or maybe
write something about how that would how
the commit has been reviewed or
something I won't go into that so the
benefits of these one line is your
commit logs are much more easy to browse
and me personally for me it helps to
write smaller commits and single purpose
commits and the big feature of it is
it's machine readable I will go to this
I think there's not readable and you can
see the angular for exemplary angular
good luck to see examples and this is
good for something like automatic change
lock creation and there is a project
named conventional change lock and
basically what it does it takes a commit
lock and positive and to MD file into a
human readable format so I don't have to
write any commit locks changelogs myself
they are just auto-generated out of my
commit message looks like this so
basically this is just a commit like fix
the commit of the type fix at the pass
and then the message or we have a commit
of the type feature with a scope cue and
then the message or we have a commit
message like performance at the compile
and you get it so there is something
like automatic version releases the
project yeah our ten seconds you
basically can do really cool stuff you
can automatically determine which
version you need to update based on your
commit message you there are choose that
can help you write better commit
messages like committed sin and it's not
that hard if you just invest some time
and my time is expired thank you
you see what happened there I just
plugged it in a network it's because I'm
using a proper operating system and I'm
probably the first guy not using a mixer
for everyone who is my talk des moines
in this morning I have to talk about
hacking games and I actually missed one
game by Google yeah you all know this
little page here
oh no we're offline maybe not all of you
know that this actually is a game you
can click it and then the still t-rex
starts running and there's obstacles and
you have to jump them and if you fail
you have to try again it this actually
will sound like a peep every time you
reach more than the score of 100 so what
can you do here
Google was very clever about it actually
and if you just open the so you don't
see any scripts in - every batch you
just see this data thing and that's not
the right one sources that is not the
right file and if you have to reload
alright because sometimes it's not
what do then is alright alright it's not
the game yeah
and now what okay that I didn't expect
but I have three minutes to fix it since
I have more time alright
maybe they fixed it because they knew
about me so I just explained you what's
happening here usually you have the
index.html and you see nothing like I
see here but actually there's only one
line but and they hurt him HTML file I
tried it with you had to scroll down for
like 1500 lines they were all empty and
then the code started to appear and then
you scroll a little bit further and you
suddenly find the update function in the
update function there's actually a
little check if there's a collision if
you just comment that block out you'd
have to do you don't have to do anything
at all just keep them running all the
way all the time and get the points and
be happy and share the screenshots with
your friends and yeah use Ubuntu
you
you recognize that hopefully so yes
that's an Arduino basically and my dear
friend here has talked about how to hack
the krob Dino on the Chrome browser I
don't like you I will try to show you in
four minutes and 46 seconds how do you
hack the chrome Dino in Arduino little
web browser of course because this is a
J as conference after all so this is a
project I've been working on know
TweetDeck but it's called cloudy boy
which is basically an older boy compiler
for for for the cloud all the boy is
basically an Arduino microcontroller
built with a screen a little screen and
some buttons so you can play games with
it and you could code your own games in
like C or C++ so we have this website
that packs all that up into a simple web
browser session and what it also has so
you might see that I have this ruff
puppy maker this is my session ID which
I won't be able to use because I don't
see my screen here okay that might be a
problem let's try it this way
and let's try this okay it worked which
is a good thing so I'm gonna hook this
up this is an electronic Legation that
basically only does one thing it flashes
your Arduino compiled code you don't you
onto the Arduino this is a basic web
connected stuff so I say my key code is
rough papi
maker hopefully this will work okay it
connected let me see if I can flush this
stuff on the device if okay
okay this demo bakes our brakes every
five minutes Oh Oh Shh okay I just hack
it so we get the D no I think I know
what the problem is let's make it a
dragon yeah I like dragons better so
they're just dead it did update the code
for it so if you ever seen something
like that the code looks like that when
you compile it for the Arduino so now
hopefully and we'll see if I can get it
to work
yeah it's the USB
on
oh and you don't know don't see it
because it's not connected to the camera
oh yeah so okay actually now this time
is going to work
twenty seconds let's see if I can make
it in time things whatever flame because
I still have ten seconds
yes save let's see if it compiles it
compiled let's see if I can flash it it
can flash it it downloads and you don't
see it why I don't see it I don't know
why I don't see it but it's on there
okay okay I want to give you a short
talk about rlea a new SPI framework
comparable to angular in sorts and let's
start right off I hope you can see it
this is the github page for irelia and
specifically for the skeleton navigation
that is a startup project that already
billed us you how we hope you can see it
a skeleton in different versions we for
es2016 and three for typescript and you
just set up to work with normal text
editor asp.net 5 or with web pack
included for bundling and let's jump
right into the skeleton and I can show
you a bit how or relay is built oh
really it's a modular framework that
means it's not
monolith but you have many small
packages you can pretty much compared to
the net phone book if you're familiar
with it and all these packages have
mostly one responsibility and they are
meant for maximum reusability so you can
combine different aspects of the
framework to get really a full framework
out of it but you don't need to use
everything you can use what you want out
of that framework this starter project
delivers many things you'd expect from
it you have a test site that has some
basic features you have guard tasks
built into it to watch it for example
and that's exactly what I do know the
type guard watch it starts a build
process what a whole thing which is
built in the skeleton navigation and it
starts a web server where you can
inspect it takes a little yes and if I
go to localhost port 9000 then we see
this sample application where you can
take a look at the data binding engine
already offers you can you can take a
look at a router which also can do that
infinitely in itself and ok no problem
let's look here because here happens the
magic mostly is convention over
configuration which means you have a
mvvm sort of pattern you have a
JavaScript file which is really plain
JavaScript in year 6 and some part 7 and
you have a template that is a HD
file and they both repair a module and
you have really strictly separated the
market from the cold that and the logic
that belongs to the market they are
coupled by data binding and that binding
is a really flexible way to decouple
your your code because you can
declaratively display all your values
from a view model or you can also give
values from your inputs to the view
model to to do stuff with it and as long
as I hoped
okay the data binding engine the cool
thing about this is it's really simple
you don't need to know very much you
couldn't basically take every HTML
attribute that we can find anywhere in
your code and if you typed up bind
that's enough that takes already a semi
binding it can be two-way one way or one
time for inputs it's to two-way so in
both values in both directions the value
can flow for every other thing it's one
way because you have no input and with
that in mind I want to show you a really
cool example to finish this off its how
powerful the data binding engine really
is I have another project here and it
has not only disturb bind but it also
has another syntax because you can swap
the syntax you can teach the framework
to use another binding syntax to do what
you already wanted to do and in this
example here I have the angular syntax
you can see that in the double brackets
here below and enclose in it I also have
to knock out syntax a bit older maybe
some of you know it and if I go to
example already have it running that's
this one it is past the code and it
performs the data binding you don't need
to believe me blindly I started another
time just to show you that's really the
part I was visiting so that's it thank
you yeah hello I'm sorry from the last
funny you all tired but I just want to
talk about about the game The Binding of
Isaac
if you it's not about that actually but
okay so if you don't know this game you
should check it out it's really awesome
and I just spend some time like on my
free time to kind of make you a small
replica in JavaScript because it's
awesome
and so that guy called the issue like
shamelessly The Binding of Isaac
oh I'm I'm gonna wait anyway and so
like you just be we canvases and images
and like venue JavaScript for fun and so
like he doesn't have any like procedural
it dungeon mechanism or anything yet but
it just I just wanted to share and uh
and play around in front of people
because it's funny and so you can shoot
right
you go that was it thank you for these